[MUSIC PLAYING]
What's your favorite
programming language, and why?
I definitely like Python.
I actually learned
to code on C and C++.
And it's a lot harder when
there are more brackets and more
complicated things.
And I feel like Python abstracts
away a lot of that while
still giving you a
lot of functionality,
and allows you to do a
lot of really cool machine
learning things.
My favorite
programming language is
Python because of ease of
use and speed of development.
And I especially love
using [INAUDIBLE]..
I like Python because
originally, I learned how
to program in C. And Python
is just a lot more high level,
and it's a lot easier to use.
I hate them all equally.
No, that's not true.
I like most
programming languages.
Lately I've been
programming in Python.
It's a fairly
convenient language.
My favorite programming
language is probably C#.
I like it because it fixed
everything that Java did wrong.
But mostly it's
become a standard
in the gaming industry.
And I really love video games.
I love being able to
program video games.
And it's a really nice,
easy-to-use language.
Honestly, I guess
I would probably
say Python, which is maybe a
boring answer, because I guess
a lot of people would say that.
But for me, it's
just really easy
to prototype and
build things quickly,
which is important
in my research.
I love Python.
I think Python is like
writing English at times.
It's almost so easy to
understand for programmers,
[? even ?] when you want to
do the low-level things, which
is incredibly powerful.
I prefer Python
because it's easy
and you can program
very easily tasks,
and you can see the
results quite quickly.
At the risk of not
being a programmer,
I do a lot of
programming in MATLAB
because that's what I know.
And it's very good for controls.
But for a real
language, I like Python.
I can say my least favorite,
also if people want that,
is C and C++, because
you make a ton of bugs
and they're impossible to solve.
Waste your whole day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]